một chung tâm lừa đạo trực tuyến, quy mồ lớn giòn nhóm người Trung Quốc tổ chức vừa bị công an chết phá.
Theo điều tra, nhóm như phạm có nguồn gấp từ các tổ chức lừa đạo trực tuyến từng hoạt động tại khẩu chiê.
Từ tháng 6 họ đưa hàng trục công dân Trung Quốc đến lưu chú tại nhiều đề điểm ở Hanoi,
lao cai và vụ thuật.
Trong đó, mười sống người không có dưới tờ nhập cảnh hợp pháp.
Để chẳng bị phát hiện, nóng này liên tục thay đổi nơi ở,
tư tiền thuyết các địa điểm giọc, khép kiến và hạn chế tiếp xúc với người dân địa phương.
Tại các cơ sở thui họ lắp đặt hàng rộng mấy tính, định thoại,
thích bị phát sống internet, bàn ghế làm việc, dừng tân và vật dục xin hoạt,
bến nơi đây thành đại bản xuân cho họ đợp lửa đạo.
Trong cuộc khám sét đồng thằng sấu, lực lượng trức năng tu dữ bẩy bị bà bộ mấy ví tính,
một trăm 8 mì tự địa phải dịch đậu, cùng nhiều thích bị lưu chữ dữ liệu,
phát sống ngoài phai, dừng tân đệm ngủ.
Công ăn phủ thỏ đã giữ bốn người trong trường hấp hình cấp,
gồm chào quý dông, còn gọi là Acho, quyến thành lâm, chân thiết thu hưởng và phạm định năng,
được sát định giữ phai trò cầm đầu đường dây.